[Music]
in creep and creeper news freckles all
the [ __ ] rich white kids had to do
hey have you guys ever watched uh that
Netflix documentary on toys or like the
toys that we had or whatever I've seen
on that what was that it was a good yeah
it's all about like the history of like
these iconic toys like GI Joe and [ __ ]
like that Legos oh man submitted by
Joe's toes there was this girl that
lived across the street that was always
skipping all the time she was fine no I
just want o cuz it went Joe's toe then
it looked like he was about to like do
it and then you start to talk that's
true I was always the cute girls with it
with skip it I wanted to skip it so I
only had it because my second grade
teacher I think she was unable to have
kids so she would ask everyone in the
Kin her classroom what they wanted for
Christmas she would buy every single cat
so nice she's coming out of her paycheck
bagging grade teacher took away my
Christmas present I had it and they
should take it away from me and I would
I wanted it so bad before I got it and
then I got it and I was so happy and I
took it to school and she took it away
right and then four years after that I
kept going visiting her class and asking
her if she could give it back like I
wanted it she just took it and never
gave it back she was playing with it
herself
if I was a teacher that's what I would
do [ __ ] first ten minutes of class
and kids bring out your [ __ ] toys and
play with that [ __ ] to your heart's
content because the next 50 minutes is
hell yeah like [ __ ] get it out of
your system Duty huh
do your skip I said turn that [ __ ] up
yeah
I don't think I ever want to put my kids
in school the horrors oh I have
nightmares
Oh oh my god that's right dad I don't
wanna do my homework damn straight you
know they never learn how to read oh
there's all thick and matted they're
gonna communicate through the real life
skills
you gotta learn how to rollerblade and
use echolocation oh they're gonna broke
clothes they're gonna be like [ __ ]
like furs and different type of [ __ ]
they hunted I'll leave cover in their
private in today we're gonna do the burr
box hunting challenge come here kids
let's go
a man was convicted of breaking into a
home and sucking on a sleeping woman's
toes no people are [ __ ] freak Eve
shrimp and dude that's what is called
shrimping is that what it's called
suckin on a tow he broke up what he
thought you might broke a law to suck
somebody's toe like that was his
intention I'm gonna break into this home
this sucks up what he's told he wasn't
even trying to steal was he trying to
steal I got another agenda and then he
thought that toast sticking out of the
sheets damn that's a fine ass I gotta
suck that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he blog back he's all I gonna get some
[ __ ] VCR smallest VCR I ever seen in
my life dude and also you got to go back
in time to get a VCR by the way I found
videotapes somebody give me a VCR all
right so this man today was Richard he's
29 years old of Norwalk oh [ __ ]
Richard Michael are curse those white
people Anala - this is what he looks
like he looks like a caveman dating to a
hinterland he looks like a tow sucker
lost some way to clean himself what all
right now he looks like a closer he
looks like two people one guy
Medine one guy I don't know so just the
beard cuz the team has a feud so anyway
that's the thing thoughtful look like he
could suck some good toe though so he
look at how luscious his lips is you
tell them they're chapped this [ __ ] they
look rough they're chapped yes no from
this if you look at it upside down like
this he looks pretty good
he has some thick lips though and that
that mouth looks soft you know what dude
you lose your weight and you prove this
lady wrong didn't shave yourself up and
stop sucking toes and we'll see all I'm
saying is if he sucks my toe I'll be
cord it man you got some nice-looking
toes thank you anybody that's willing to
suck the [ __ ] toe jam off my feet
thank you very much
see that's a service that's what I'm
saying all right so this dude Richard
what he did here is he saw this woman
walking her dog and then he told her on
what streets third I don't believe it
there's no third in Norwalk third until
Inga
dude there's always a third not and
everyone want renders main street you
told a nice dog and then nice dog and
feet
and then you can't help us safety here
those numbers up and said I am walking
mine too
oh that's pretty funny did he put his
dick have a collar on it too and like a
little leash I'm walking mine too that
does not look like he would be doing
[ __ ] like that it gets weirder I wonder
if he practiced that line to God I'm
walking mine too yeah he does it in
front of the mirror perfect though she
was oh that's funny it must be a
chihuahua a cheetah Wonka cheeks cheeks
PETA just have better rebuttals and it
would scare that creeps away but when
chicks go oh it turns them on alright so
then later that same day knock into her
home while she was sleeping how did he
even find and then she woke up and found
him I kicked that [ __ ] in his
face and then the next day this fool you
peeped into an apartment through the
mail slot and then told the resident
that his girlfriend was attractive got
some issues yeah so then later that day
a female jail guard caught him touching
himself while looking at her a jail
guard because the he got arrested before
looking through the mailbox and sucking
the toes but not while he's at jail he's
touching himself looking at a male jail
bar so he starts beating off while she's
like walking around yep and then there's
a strong libido he started saying that
he is a Zeus like God who was sent from
the stars to seduce women it was his
destiny to abuse women and they would
willingly have his children yes ma'am
the planet may be [ __ ] Walmart
theology thang he won't he will create a
super race super8 it looks like you got
shitty genetics though so he has a god
complex too his attorney said that he
stopped taking his medication for
schizophrenia
after
oh there you go cuz he kind of looks
more like that thing in Hercules versus
actual Zeus you know that goat that
trainer Kiwis that will look more like
corridor than anything that will look
like corridor oh but he didn't take his
medication because his girlfriend died
yeah and then he started hearing voices
coming from the television telling him
to do things and that huge it doesn't
belong in jail then he belongs in the
[ __ ] he needs he needs help
yeah and like a mental mental
institution if you look at his mugshot
though it seems like nothing nothing is
happening behind those eyes right right
and I do differently huh now you know
the whole story now it's like empty head
and then an image of a foot comes up and
he's like oh yeah a lot of crazy people
in this woman yeah I mean that that kind
of explains somewhat Richard my all the
crazy [ __ ] that he's doing is he he's
like he has no sense of reality
he's like living in his own world you
know be you know be kind of cool if like
if we could unharmed a experience what
it's like to be these different types of
mental type of states not be tight so
like one day you can experience yeah
you'd be would appreciate it can't come
back from it though no you can't kid
more my technology you can't harm me
yeah it's like a roller coaster ride you
know so it's like you just put on your
[ __ ] today I am going to be a
schizophrenic you know crazy today I'm
going to be Africa yeah
what would you pick besides
schizophrenic person I'm very interested
in schizophrenia and this is kind of
similar like which is multi-personality
disorder oh yeah yeah multiple
personality doesn't hear or like do they
know that there's these different people
living within themselves it's kind of
weird how some people use like these
hardcore drugs and they've never had
like a psychotic breakdown or something
but they'll use like DMT or some [ __ ]
and next thing you know they're [ __ ]
loony like it either they had that
tendency or trait before or did that
drug do that to them I think it's just
like the their mental fortitude it's
very weak yeah like it turned it on yeah
like acid people can really go down yeah
yeah I've done a lot of acid in my
formidable years when my brain is still
developing from 14 to 16 and holy Christ
all of Christ it just it changed my mind
is all I'm saying it's like [ __ ] I
wonder if how different you would be if
you didn't do that stuff yeah you feel
like you changed after I think this is
what happened in elementary school I was
already a hyper as kid lots of energy
very outgoing and then I got into drugs
and I got depressed and all that [ __ ]
and I was very internal so like I wasn't
acting outward a lot of things were
going on in here and then my world was
like I was like a [ __ ] I was like a
[ __ ] what do you call those creatures
a possum you know go out in the middle
the night [ __ ] spray paint with my
friends and come back home and [ __ ] you
know go to raves in the middle of the
night [ __ ] do drugs and [ __ ] you know
and it was pop like a party party
there's no Alvin La opossums are like
mischievious looking dude damn a party
possum you know and then yeah and then
when I sobered up because I felt I
didn't feel normal unless I was on
something when I was sober I started
feeling like weird like I couldn't sleep
and I think it's because like you're
confronted with thoughts you don't want
to be in the real world you want to
escape so then once you're forced with
being in the real world it almost felt
like
for almost a decade of my life if I've
been living in a dream world and now I
have to face being a human and I have to
deal with my problems and I had this
like stunted growth and maturity and
everything so then now fast forward to
like college and on I felt like I was
experiencing things most people do in
earlier years but I didn't get that
opportunity to work things out like like
you know social skills relationship
skills yeah because if you think about a
50 year old druggie right sometimes they
have the maturity of a 10 year old right
or whatever right is it's an escape yeah
yeah yeah well like the the the hot mom
party girls that like never grow up
they're like they're like late 40s and
[ __ ] they're still trying to be like
they're 21 but they're just alcoholics
like crazy and they never stop partying
since 21 yeah they're stuck at that
stage well that's when drugs become
dangerous when you use it as an escape
versus like recreation right like oh
yeah
once I started smoking weed when I was
like 12 it was I had anger issues and it
really helped me kind of like chill me
out and then I when you weren't smoking
dope weren't you ain't yes I had yeah
yeah yeah so like if it came to the
point where being high was my normal
state like I did that to stay normal but
then like you said once you kind of get
to a certain point you realize I got a
deal with this [ __ ] you know I can't
just like use drugs to kind of like
escape from it or to suppress it like
you got a deal with it in my drug pie
that's my exact it's healthy but it's
also good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]